hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast please
take a second to subscribe to the
YouTube channel that way you get the
episodes as they come out thanks a lot
welcome to another exciting edition of
ru garbage the show where you find out
if your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage it's the show where we sit
down with your favorite comedians and
find that if they grew up classy or if
as the Italians say they are ganna
Biagio
I'm your host H Foley coming at you on a
beautiful night here in a story of
queens the world's borough ladies and
gentlemen you can smell the revolution
in the air my co-host back in New York
City came right back in the nick of time
to save us all our good pal Kevin James
Ryan everybody hey gang had to vacate
the belt of king of the boardwalk and I
am back to claim the Big Apple baby at
least for the next 48 hours a couple of
tax purposes I had to get back to take
care of you know what I mean
pick up the mail make a phone call grab
a shower or above the door keep up
appearances you know what the neighbors
know I'm still around runs the block
yeah happy to be here guys thanks so
much for listening if you haven't
already please rate review subscribe on
iTunes also as you know the full video
is available on YouTube make sure you
subscribe and check that out thank you
mmm very nice and as you folks know that
patreon is up and running
we highly recommend everybody getting on
the old patreon train here what are you
garbage and everybody that has signed
that we appreciate it that's why we're
gonna kick this episode off right now
with some of the subscriber question is
that we have in the vault Kevin Ryan
let's rock and roll
what do you get guys first of all thanks
so much the [ __ ] patreon we just
this week and it's [ __ ] cooking we're
our first goal is a hundred patrons we
wanted to reach we're already [ __ ]
halfway there so if you haven't already
joined at a hunt once we get a hundred
patrons
I will go to Foley's [ __ ] parents
house and we're gonna do a garbage style
and TV cribs and [ __ ] see what kind of
filthy really did come from well get
some eyes on the pool get a man on the
street down there in Bluebell we're
gonna put out the good paper plates when
you come to come Oh the wax-covered ones
I get that car off the lawn kippis come
and brush your hair the old bank we got
company guys Bob as you know so once you
do because we get so many submissions of
people sending us questions we can't get
to all of them so what we're doing is if
you joined the patreon we will read
yours on an episode so that's what we're
doing now we're gonna knock out a couple
each time as they come in so all right
first one comes from our boy odd staff
hey thank you buddy
did a parent ever siphon gas out of
another family members car and I gotta
be honest yeah without their note
without their knowledge no but he says
bonus points if you smoke - cig well
doing it and if it was a step kids car I
don't I don't ever remember my father
turning the car off or putting out a
cigarette
any time we went to a gas station oh
never I didn't know your dad used to
catch Bernie's yeah he's Marlboro Reds
gotten it out with Charlie he was Reds
baby right though right yeah I wrote he
wrote a [ __ ] cow a horse back they
trade it in all his Marlboro miles they
get off at the you know [ __ ]
thoroughbred you take that home from
Vietnam I for sure I have you my stepdad
for sure siphoned gas out of my cousin's
car it was the 90s so I'm sure there was
Winston's either doering or if not right
before and or right after and I didn't
know what he was doing he was trying to
get the car start and I look over at one
point he's like he's nuts he's part of
the car at one point he's got two hoses
he's spitting and suck it was like a
goddamn orgy underhood have you ever
done that if you ever siphoned it got
into your mouth a little bit you never
spit the gas out siphon what do I
[ __ ] look siphon I'm a [ __ ]
white-collar guy so you think I'm
slaving in my own gas dude I don't even
know how to change my oil what are you
talking about siphoning gas what dude
have you ever met I don't I don't I only
go to full-service gas pumps you're
telling me you don't know the taste of
gasoline smell used to put a cup a
couple of drops on my buds to keep him
roasted no I think get the high-octane
stuff my parents still tell a famous
story real quick about our first dog
Mike which dude what was your uncle guys
cleaned up Uncle Mike's coming over I
don't know why they did to Mike German
Shepherd your parents are [ __ ]
hillbillies that's why they claimed they
named him Mike and they probably claimed
them on the taxes um a killer attack dog
but in the late 70s we had it we have
here whose get out of here he's just
yelling at everybody from the front
porch in the 70s they had a recession
right so late 70s my dad was when my dad
was still a teamster he was still
driving driving a truck see you know
he'd be gone overnight and some some
poor bastard was trying to siphon gas
out of my mom's car out in the front of
our house [ __ ] German Shepherd jumps
right through the plate-glass window on
the front chased that dude down the
[ __ ] Street
my mom had a [ __ ] wake up run after
him get the neighbors they caught him
but that dude ain't walking right I'll
pay that right man there ain't happy
might get a bowl full of some guys nuts
that night all right this one comes from
Deadeye Dave and I know Foley's to get a
bit weird
back in the day so who knows or this
Deadeye Dave have you ever stayed at a
sex themed hotel now yeah two two
fancy for you you couldn't get the
scratch together to get the $200 deposit
fee
I stayed in a regular hotel and sexed it
up myself
whacked off and every squared square
inch of that Motel six room jerking off
in a garage count because what the
[ __ ] is sex like Neil like in the
Poconos I go Archie I've done shows at
them where I've had to stay actually
refused to say because you walk in and
it that place is sticky icky icky
dude that's a hookin did I so I do I
thought it's Corona boy that's where
Corona fight has started dude I was
afraid of touching doorknob I was afraid
to touch anything the condom on all the
time but also if you're going to a sec
dude and I know because I performed one
at one it's [ __ ] like they have the
heart-shaped tubs the [ __ ] big
martini glass at with you know hot tubs
all that [ __ ] wacky weird [ __ ] and
it's like if you're going to one of
those you are [ __ ] trash and I knew
was gonna be trashy because they told me
in the email I can't wear jeans or shoes
I have to wear like I guess in there I
like slacks and [ __ ] a pair of dress
shoes if you call it slacks you're trash
trash my videos to chinos or Cheetos is
trashed my dad was a big slacks and
dungarees guy that's a nice pair of
dungarees you got there and he used to
call women handsome handsome woman right
there oh man that and sharp sharp was a
big one oh that jacket sharp you're
[ __ ] weird dude Cleveland when I'm
looking at these people and they show up
in like basketball shorts and like
cutoff t-shirts and I'm like I gotta get
rid of the [ __ ] yeah I'm like I can't
dressed up for these [ __ ] hillbillies
who paid to come to a sec so tell I've
always wanted when I was younger and
we'll have fantasies alone in my room at
night I always wanted to go to like
hedonism or something like that the
rippin and the tearin baby the rippin
and lit they're there see that video
Google it's weird
okay this one's [ __ ] super funny this
is from Bob after how many cousins
neighbor named Heather do you have home
[ __ ] wrong
Heather is a garbage [ __ ] name dude I
don't have any but that's [ __ ] a
whole layer there should be at least
seven in my family I was in love with I
was in love I was in love love here in
[ __ ] elementary school with a girl
named Heather Heather ribbon dancing now
where's she end up Nowheresville PA hey
we're gonna mount sinai I'll take it at
if she is she's got the room now
Heather Wow no Heather's Heather's a try
as a tough name yeah Heather's are
really Heather it's a hungry it's a hot
girls name Heather yeah Heather's a hot
girls name for the wrong side of the
tracks though yes yeah wrong hutch yes I
can do all the down man I have there
Heather babysat yeah you know Heather
baby Sally and her boyfriend came over
and [ __ ] piped her the second you
fell asleep watching [ __ ] dukes of
hazzard sounds oddly specific but sure
thanks a lot Derek my mom never got that
out of the couch either
that was my favorite recliner
yeah what else is real trash lazyboy -
we had a lousy boy growing up that was
you thought you made it if you got a
lazy boy you know my pop has like a
mechanical chair it's a lazy boy but it
lifts him up because of the Parkinson's
it lifts them and lifts them up and out
of the out of the chair it's like a
forklift like a forklift for kleiner and
it's it's got a massage it's got heat
Hey go go gadget goober over there take
that thing for a test drive I was home
Oh wrong with that question this is a
real this'll determine if you have
garbage ebar hey guys they're heather
one man who was that I can own run Bob
Hafner Oh
Bobby that was beautiful guy your dad
Parkinson's chair question is at least
their own that chair well you making
payments on said chair for more easy
payments I will be excuse me now it's I
it's paid for it was there I think it
was a grand those a jihad oh it's more
than the car after house got insurance
on it too
alright this is from Juan Smith shot at
the 1 e 1 e y8 has a family member ever
has all Jesus has a family ever been
assaulted by their spouse at a family
reunion maybe over a card game game a
Crazy Eights went south huh Go Fish
you stupid [ __ ] what the [ __ ] go
forever maybe over wait who's playing
cards what's going on sing sing where
you read who's playing cards well we
would so my family's big Irish Catholic
[ __ ] knuckleheads
you know big boozers and you know no one
ever really dealt with any emotions
let's call it hmm so we've been playing
like board games you know what I mean
like down the shore or whatever you know
I'll get out [ __ ] you know they're
cheesy or whatever look at the Ouija
board and see if we can talk to uncle
Ned fine fine they were grandpa buried
the buried is huge we and there's been
fistfights like we've there's been board
games a turn into Facebook or cheesy now
but between Koz deserves a gap
the apples was one of them you know all
the apples to apples what the balloons
and ladders woody
yes I'll [ __ ] morons I don't know
monopoly like a [ __ ] gentleman we buy
some property start leasing the things
get your hands on a railroad or
something like just get your hands on a
Parkinson's chair who's gonna get that
thing talk about a whole bunch of
personal like you know whatever but my
parents were down at the shore house
Shannon was well what they were getting
new couches delivered so they were like
you guys gotta get rid of the old
couches you can get whatever garbage I
Carolee em whatever you get for me yours
you just need him you keep the cash just
move the units you know why did you move
him whoo but I'm on Craigslist for 250
Wow settled for two got 150 art [ __ ]
chicks down here for senior week took me
for a ride yeah I mean dude I'm talking
about an all-time low in your life
you're selling your parents use
furnitures to other losers on Craigslist
can you do 225 I'm like holy [ __ ] all
right let's do one more and then we'll
wrap it up and get into the episode very
nice this was a two-parter uh well just
do one have you ever thrown gas on a
fire who's this from
oh I'm sorry this is from Zach Zach
Thank You Zach uh yes I have like a
[ __ ] congressman I'm sorry thank you
very thank you very much for your great
question mr. mr. Smith I guess I have a
used lighter fluid to start a barbecue
yeah it's the coolest thing ever
throwing gas on a on a fires pretty cool
pretty pretty dangerous - yeah that sure
doesn't go out easily yeah you get your
hands on some [ __ ] you get your hands
on some gas from like a buddies you know
[ __ ] mower or something
take that threw them down to the ones we
put it in a squirt bottle and we didn't
realize and we were squirting it from
the squirt bottle onto the fire that we
started wearing the stream catches right
the thing catches - the bottle down the
tip of the bottles on fire we got a
flamethrower or [ __ ] I'm like it's
like [ __ ] running man down there - go
up - or [ __ ] torch and everything it
was [ __ ] I see that's a real garbage
Christians act by the way that that's
what your head would go is there a
second part to that now he'd submitted
two questions but there's one more is
having this is from Ryan doe shout out
to Ryan as having three gas containers
garbage in the garage if you
it depends is what does one have the mix
in it if you got thing you got scent or
stroke mix yeah it's obviously fine okay
that's the only leaves then - why do you
need - if you need if you need three
cans of gas and you're not working at a
motor shop or something something up
something's ain't ain't right I've never
needed one other than to fill up the
weed whacker or whatever you know I
would say who stroked bad news if you
got multiple gas cans yeah they're both
half filled one's got a little water in
it so you can't use it that's a real
tragedy
don't use the big one don't use a big I
order in it that is some garbage
questions gang ah the old patreon I love
it that's [ __ ] awesome Russians if
you haven't already please sign up doing
a lot of cool [ __ ] over there we're
doing weekly bonus episodes of are you
garbage we have weekly episodes of me
and Foley's other podcasts that we used
to do called hard feelings and plus
we're doing live streams and stuff like
that so go to WWE TRL calm
/ are you garbage the link will be in
the description of this check it the
[ __ ] out we're cooking baby that's right
now it's time for the episode let's
[ __ ] go again we are so excited to
have our very very very special guests
here with us today this young man
performs all over New York City all over
the country he's been a writer for
joking off and the roast of Rob Lowe
ladies and gentlemen Brendan Sangalo
what are you shaking her head at do huh
you read my bio yeah I had to read your
bio it was only two sentences I gotta
get rid of that Rob Lowe thing because
here's the thing about that Rob I
contributed a joke to someone who was
writing for it and when I wrote that bio
you know how lie I got it [ __ ] I
gotta take that off so I was like you're
this generations rich Foss money to a
guy named Oscar maybe thanks for doing
the show buddy yeah buddy thanks for
having for coming on man we was just a
segment on your other podcast yeah yeah
this was uh you know it's somebody
started playing it a few years ago just
on Center City comedy and then you know
now look at us now but you've been
you've been requested quite it quite a
good amount mm-hmm well [ __ ] a lot of
people know how trash I am and how
garbage I am yeah I think that's kind of
the that's the thing with this episode
for the listener out there we know I
mean talk about an easy win I mean
sometimes you sometimes you need to give
me but you know what I mean this whole
episode is just redundant this is this
is every fight that rocky had right
before clubber lang these these are the
setups right here it's a do not matter
now and I'm being serious I want you to
be as open and honest because I know
you're garbage
okay but I have this vision in my head
of what I think you grew
like and what you did and I really want
to know if what my fantasy meets the
actual yeah aren't you two kind of the
same age to Kevin I'm I'm older than him
I'm 33 or what I just turned 29
okay yes we're definitely the same world
and we end we we work almost everything
in person no what was the same person do
it like the skateboarding in the bands
the canto it's the final do we were just
mentioning hello it in the greenroom
we're like small boxes the mission to
suburban mischief and [ __ ]
oh yeah just wearing like etnies
sneakers and go to the mall and running
away from security guards in a yellow
card or whatever the [ __ ] you I can
smell the sleep over sweat on you that's
what tell us a little bit about about
exactly where you grew up and how you uh
I grew up in a little place called Sai
Asik have you heard of it okay
alumni and called garbage everybody it's
actually not a bad town like it's very
it's actually very wealth its wealthy
and then there's like upper middle class
and then that's pretty much it like then
there was a trailer park that nobody
went to dude that's always we we have we
have a joke on here of like if you're in
a trailer park in this sub like in like
a regular area that's a you're the only
trailer park that's it if you're in a
neighborhood where there's a bunch of
trailer parks that's fine but when
you're the only one that's the wrong
side of the trailer park was right next
to the Ralph's Italian ices so you'd see
it every time you got Ralph's that's did
you everything how's anybody in there
no there was one kid his name was Moses
he was the only black kid he was a year
older than me and he lived there but I
never I never talked to him I never any
like you know not done work there was
one black kid in your town that was it
there's one black kid there was him and
then this guy Camacho I don't
joking there was others but you know
it's uh it was what are you trying to
get me I'm sorry sweat me to say here if
I'm trying to paint a picture of how
garbage you down is it wasn't it's
garbage in a sense where there was a lot
of like emo kids and goth kids what did
your parents do my both my parents were
my parents are lawyers but my mom
retired at like at like 40 why stopped
working and my dad worked for AIG until
the big you know the recession of 2008
and so he quit but he said he quit
because they're criminals but I think he
quit because they weren't promoting him
after a couple of conversations with him
he like he was like he's gotta like I
stood up for what was right for this
country and then and then after talking
to him for a long wait a minute hold on
why did your mother retire because
because we we had the money before the
recession we had the money for her to
retire and just watch me and my sister
and then and then the recession hit and
then my mom should have went back to a
job but she never got a job to like five
years ago as a lawyer she's a lawyer now
yeah but like for you know raise or some
funds of her she's her own she's her own
lawyer and a slip-and-fall case you all
saw that he pushed me yeah but it is a
dog cone he couldn't afford the real
code the difference that's on paper
that's pretty classy your father was an
attorney for AIG like dollar that's good
he's an educated man yeah he went to
Georgetown University mm-hmm I'm pretty
sure
and then this pointed well there was at
one point a couple years ago he was like
he was saying how proud of me he was and
then he went there was a couple years
where we thought you were gone he said
that we were we were worried about you
kiddo
now am I now yeah I just picture him at
like [ __ ] Christmas he's got his
alright he's like my boy writes for a
roast of Rob Lowe but he contributed to
some guy who was writing you guys never
see st. Elmo's fire
get over here Brendan yeah he's a pretty
educated guy but he's a piece of [ __ ]
too
so like my family is like their trash
but they're like hidden trash you know
what I mean or you do your middle-class
suburban trash yeah and that that's
that's the I love that because yeah it
was like a great upbringing and it was
like fun but you kind of knew in the
back of your head that you were that you
were garbage well you don't even know
until you leave you know that's the
thing when you experience people that
aren't garbage you're like yeah hey what
the [ __ ] you're like that's what this
whole podcast doesn't be like holy [ __ ]
what are these green things they're peas
oh my god like tamama is about this I
didn't even realize I was garbage until
I talked to guys like you who are likely
like you're like oh you must have loved
monster energy yeah what's wrong with
that
oh yeah yeah dude I do the dude what's
up we had those like plastic black
skateboard ramps you know what I'm
talking about the launch ramps the
plastic all the time but they were so
bad because they were so light you had
to put like rocks on him or something so
you'd be going down a hill to like go
off of them and the ramp they would push
back instead of actually going on them
and then you'd [ __ ] just you'd fall
every time alright let's get into some
questions here didn't really quite paint
the picture of growing up we're gonna
get into it more questions did you have
any brothers and sisters I had an older
sister I have
three years yt making that face because
I said I had it older she died in a
launch ramp accident on the cul-de-sac
she's my mom so she don't talk to me no
more you know what was real trash which
we did a lot because they were building
houses like in my area all the time
with steel wood for the construction
site so it'll build a ramp with that was
I go you're walking uh she was like a
big piece of plywood yeah taking a piss
house who has a hammer and nails and
[ __ ] go to town yeah yeah my mom
wants my when my first dog died she she
told me I can make a halfpipe in my
backyard oh did you have the Hat with
stolen wood yeah the wood though I'm not
stealing the wood for you rusty wasn't
even a full-size dog they're all
different types and sizes of wood yeah
there was always one kid in every town
whose parents would let them buy their
let him build a [ __ ] panpipe in the
backyard and I remember was this kid
Bretton I'm like his parents must be
insane like this is crazy my mom's like
you're not even going over there dude I
had a my friend Evan my like first
friend ever who lives around the block
for me
he had a halfpipe in his backyard we
would jump off of his roof into the pool
and stuff and he also had a he had a
halfpipe in his basement so it was like
he'd built one in his basement you just
go down as this little thought it was so
cool dude
heat over his house I did eat at his
house and it was a different experience
president like a ratings athlete at most
houses yeah they didn't even invite me I
was just eating in the corner no but
like that kind of kid that was uh that
there's always something wrong with the
family a little bit they were the
parents were a little off or something
it wasn't his dad was like a drunk and
his mom and his sister like divorced the
family like his mom and his sister moved
away and left him his older brother
is his dad cuz they all went to rehab
together I guess Jesus Christ yeah and
his his dad's name was Steve and he who
actually just asked my mom for money a
couple of months ago they haven't been
talking and he just [ __ ] he like all
of them are doing except for that kid
Evan like his dad Steve asked for money
his older brother Ryan showed up to my
house and like ass was like banging on
the door and my mom called the police
she like didn't answer the door she's
right there's like 1:00 in the morning
anyway that was like my best friend
growing up sounds like a real
straight-shooter the dad asked him for
money
did she give the dad the money she
didn't give him money now what was the
sum of money do you remember I could I
don't know I gotta ask her about it but
it felt like it was something like 75
bucks it could have been $75 it could
have been two thousand two thousand
respectable means you can see your yeah
means your end up but you're not just
like nickel and diming somebody yeah I
need 68 bucks
you're like 68 bucks get out of here
have some [ __ ] respect and ask for a
jihad you know what I mean yeah she's
asking for gas money from my mom all
right let's get into it here are you
garbage our good pal mr. Brendan sagol
Oh Brendan we're gonna ask you a series
of questions to find out how much
garbage you are so one fact Long Island
Trees yes so far real real sketchy all
right first of all Ralph's Italian ice
is [ __ ] I got a Biagio yeah I feel
like it's just somebody just stealing
Slurpees and just make it a little bit
colder ice was just three different
colored ice that they put together
all right let's kick it off I want to do
a couple the basics with that which just
could just because I'm curious
growing up you lived in a single-family
home correct yes for I mean my my
parents my parents separated
when I was answers already nicely I got
I think I'm back together separated when
I was like 12 but my dad lived there
till I was like 18
wait so I think are they married still
now they're divorced now they got them
till I was 25 to get divorced and then
my dad the next day married his
girlfriend Jesus Christ ways of our
lives arbitrary wait so your parents a
divorce and then lived in the same house
yeah my dad would sleep in while my mama
and then I would swear would you sleep
with your mom
yeah I'd sleep with my mom and everybody
else was Evans old man was cuz he knew
when I come for money I think Evans old
family was trying to get a taste I would
sleep in the den and then eventually my
dad if you called to Dan that's trash
you have a dental exam room family room
not a den and then cells underground the
Flintstones if you're hanging out of the
den you're definitely smoking cigs
inside cigarettes inside yeah in the
dead Dan has like an open pit fire with
like laundry in it what did you what did
you call them I call it the living room
living room the dining room the kitchen
we got a California split-levels all
these houses underground at three
different points
yeah get it on the roof you go
underground you come back up everything
that's so funny you guys like Gophers
it's like the Alamo prairie-dogging it
all over the house yeah if you looked at
from a from a side view of Foley's house
it's just a series of tunnels you get
the cross section in there they might
they might have called it - Dan I'm not
sure it was the definitely the basement
we called it the basement well that's
one of those things that I didn't even
know was trashy until this conversation
I think yeah I know yeah what up so you
had what you call the rooms like the
common rooms the dan wait hold on hold
on hold on I cannot move forward with
this your parents separated when you
were 12 they come down they sit you and
your sister down they say hey we're
getting separated but we're gonna live
in the same house so Brendon you got to
give up your room and then the other
critters my parents so I went on this
snowboarding trip with my buddy Matt and
I sprained my ankle like a day in and my
parents came to pick me up and it was
like in the Catskills so it's like a
two-hour ish drive I think and they told
me as we were leaving the hotel that
they're separating right so I like
that's something wait till the end of
the ride until you're pulling into the
neighborhood it was so annoying I told
them stuff like I wanted them to feel
guilty so I said I'm gonna be a bad kid
if you guys said that to him and I was
sleeping and then I I woke up for a
second because they were arguing in the
front seat and I figured out what they
were arguing about what they're getting
separated at about is that my dad was
talking to this other woman at work like
very closely and she he asked her if he
should shave his balls for my mom and
he's like I did it for you I like I woke
up to that and being like I don't know
for us for you and she's like you don't
ask another woman if you want to shave
your balls
[Laughter]
Brendan what the [ __ ] yeah and I didn't
even tell them I was up I just sat satin
in it I also like out of that whole
story Sacco gets in the car his parents
get well he's a 12 year old fat kid his
parents give him the most devastating
news that they're getting aboard a
divorce and then he passes out and goes
to bed you couldn't have been that torn
apart if you liked all that soft Solan
wood in the backseat
wait did you ever find that if your dad
did shave his balls around he did is
that the woman times that the woman that
he started started that he ended up
marrying no this woman's name was Wendy
I think he definitely nailed that chick
though maybe but my my mom this is the
want to hear something trashy
my mom has sister left her a voicemail
[ __ ] away from my husband you're ruining
my family Ross Reese's about that oh my
god that is that's that's a family level
garbage your mom is garbage I mean your
mom's mom was garbage that's like oh
yeah the whole the whole thing the whole
Long Island just breeds trash dude man
that Mayflower must have been stinky
trash on that thing I'm pretty sure how
man I don't know if I should I'm pretty
sure my dad did cheat on my mom though
because I know for sure once he brought
some chicken to your room your dad's
friend Stacy yeah you remember Phyllis
from work my mom one time my parents are
arguing and they're screaming at each
other one night and me and my sister are
like just like in in it we're just in it
I remember us being in the den listening
to them [ __ ] going at it and we were
always taking my dad's side for some
reason like he was always kind of like
the good cop between them so we were
like mom
like like yelling at her she goes you
want to know why I'm mad because your
dad [ __ ] a prostitute and like said
that I was like [ __ ] I was like 13
years old yeah Jesus current dude that
urine your family is in the back of your
head were you like all right way to go
dad play with the pros I see so at 12
they get separated your dad moves into
your your bedroom a boy's bedroom at the
age of 12 he said I don't need to remind
anybody that's like the fortress whose
Solitude yeah yeah so you got to get out
of your room yeah and I slept in the den
for a little bit and then and then he
started sleeping with my mom a little
bit
like in the same bedroom you know just
whatever I don't know balls chicks from
work taking your room guys all right you
should be on the show he's a good dude
but then after a while like I started
sleeping in my room
from for a couple years and he would
like go to hotels and stuff and then
when I was in college he got a how he
got an apartment in Jersey City - and I
lived there for a little your dad was
sleeping in hotels for extended periods
of time as day yeah that's rough man
yeah I wouldn't just like rent a place
for like 900 bucks a month and Long
Island why did he move out when you were
12 when they said they were getting
separated I don't know because they just
he just wouldn't like there would be
some nights where he wouldn't be there
and he would just be like staying out at
a hotel or whatever I have no idea and
then some nights where he would stay and
he'd sleep in my room or he'd sleep in
we had a guest room
a little bit that was like my old room
and then when they we built a part of
the house that's all you guys had an
addition we got an addition that's
trashy yeah they gotta be Beth they can
be nice but they gotta be done well
otherwise additions you're like did you
just [ __ ] glue this onto the side of
your house I think it was good now the
kitchens upstairs the lockers in one
room the dryers in another [ __ ] is going
on in here
but yeah eventually my dad moved to
Jersey City that is a strange upbringing
preferred to be that young to be like 12
13 in those formative years to have all
that going on him living there
that's [ __ ] and then and then you
improved on the house at some point
during all that was really really fine
they probably got a good right to refi
and put money back in the back in the
place you know well they would they
would fight all the time but they were
trying to make it work I think like like
let's make it work until you know they
go to just get out of our den was your
mom was your mom dating during this time
trash you are you just called an
addition an extension we get an extender
on a house over there the real trash you
move is to is to when the garage is
attached to the house to make the garage
the new living room yeah I know people
have done feel you know you're walking
on concrete when you're walking it like
yeah I don't care how much padding and
carpet you put down when you step into a
room a family room that was a garage you
know yeah and there's like bugs
everywhere more still there I lived
above the garage my room was above the
garage
it gets colder than one of those
[Music]
unravelled and oh I'm telling you it's
all gonna be like that
okay speaking of let's get these out of
the way speaking of garages did you so
you had a garage did you have a garage
was a refrigerator in that garage no and
that's the one that I was thinking of
when I was earlier when I was like oh I
know that they asked if there's a fridge
in your garage and I didn't have one Wow
so just one fridge in the whole house
if there was no way back though I just
remembered there was there wasn't a
fridge but there was a bunch of like
waters and stuff just like like that was
our storage for drinks but we know
fridge okay there'd be like there'd be
that remember in the summer every once
in a while
that's a weird level of trash but yeah
in the summer a warm soda would be would
would it would hit the spot
and I'm talking about like a cold grape
soda or a warm grape soda if elegant
burned your mouth when it was like if
you pulled it out of the garage in
August it was like [ __ ] hot to the
point where it would singed the top of
your mouth like pizza my mom would would
keep her true blue one hundreds in the
garage she had like cartons of it so I
would steal those from the garage you're
buying a car and that's game seven if
you're buying a card and calling your
husband's mistress that's [ __ ] Troy
would the true Blues are the true Blues
the ones that have like that like it was
like a like a crosshair in the filter
yeah I think so where it was like it
kind of had like a Newport II kind of
feel to it in the filter or something I
don't remember they were there were long
white cigarettes that were like gross
she smoked with the insurance when we
when I was smoking them cuz I was young
he said like they he said that I was
smoking old lady cigarettes
I can't whatever they don't [ __ ] 11
get the [ __ ] out of my face I'm not
walking through the [ __ ] Outlander
there's a backhoe outlet Oh ladies
cigarettes
dude that garage have a garage door
opener it did yeah it did I want one in
the car and then one right on the side
of it where are you the combination yeah
yeah I remember those things dropped we
got one I was like dude what
work for NASA dude the [ __ ] the
numbers would always get the numbers
that you press would always like rub off
you could but anybody could find out
what the combination is you just went
through all four combinations like a
thousand times
yeah it's like two four one two one four
two four yeah well you guys had that you
had the the garage lock will you put in
the code yeah that's what I'm talking
about we had a garage door opener like a
remote one but you don't have to know
when the combo came out and like that
mid 90s like the flip around keys yeah
it's like all I got the code or you but
you got the color oh he knows the code
you know the code yeah that's rich kid
[ __ ] right there and I was I was
middle-class America right there baby
all right only what do you got you said
that you you meant you had mentioned
earlier in the broadcast that you were
in a musical group yeah in high school I
was in a wall three boys pop punk band
called toxic toast and we would play we
played like we actually played shows we
played like VFW's and [ __ ] and like I
wanted to be Billie Joe Armstrong slash
Tonda long that was like my dream well
you had the broken home cannonbolt inner
rock success what did you form this
supergroup it was me Ted Nugent it was
uh we were 17 till about 18 so it was
like no reunion tour however I got
married if you know what I'm saying
scammers can't release his first album
and his best of in this thing same week
we uh we had a house party at my buddy
Luke's who was the drummer of the band
and we in the middle of the house party
we were like planning to have a show so
we told everybody like going to the
backyard we're gonna have a show and we
were just [ __ ] awful and it was like
maybe the worst experience for everybody
did after wash
- crawling and thinking about it
thinking about you and like you did you
know you did your hair - how you wanted
it to be done of course like I was
wearing a black bandana around my head
like where my hair would come out but it
was like this you know
yeah like the flat along the front yeah
what instrument did you play in the band
leave guitar baby and he mean lead
guitar there's no guitar there was a
three-piece there was no and I was the
lead singer classically trained I assume
well I was really trying to be like toms
along or I'd be like like whining while
I'm singing do you remember a name of
one of your songs
yes one of them was what would you say
would be your guys biggest commercial
what was our single yeah yeah at the
name of it it was like max knew the name
was one of the one of the names of it
max max knew the name yeah not a bad
name for a song but the song had nothing
to do with anyone named max or anything
we were just like let's name it this
like that's what's artsy about it
the song way that's what's artsy about
it I like that yeah right artsy sure I'm
being serious
yeah the first song I wrote was called
sunny day I would like write songs about
my girlfriend at the time and stuff and
like sing it to her one time I called my
girlfriend's phone and it went to
voicemail and I sang her Wonderwall
while playing guitar that's
cringe-worthy
Oh
I was in a band with my buddy hold on
hold on when you datin the chick from
your dad's work at this yeah I was like
Wendy this is for you
we gonna stay Kip I'm sorry I was I was
in a band of my buddy come out we were
like you know 13 or 4 I don't even know
how old were 15 and he came down so yeah
you know my uncle gave me some like a
box of his old records and stuff and
like I found a journal in there I think
there's some lyrics we can use you said
we could use them I'm like okay I open
it up hey guys I'm like you think these
are actually really good and I look at
it and it's it's it says we're two lost
souls swimming in a fish bowl year if
there is if you think we can use that
like I think somebody already has the
rights to that when you [ __ ]
plagiarize and dirtbag on that
coordinate dude read these lyrics that
my uncle came up with I know I don't
know who was lying to me all right
Oh have you ever been or anyone in your
family everybody considered a Juggalo or
a jig let yeah I mean I get I get people
calling me a Juggalo to this day still
but I've no no I'm I hate the Insane
Clown Posse or at least I did because I
was a big of an infant once they stopped
doing PCP at their shows they really
okay so you never actually participated
no I I didn't like that kind of music I
would assume this has to be yes based on
the history that you've laid out in
front of us the lineage have you ever
had a sexual encounter with a gigolo
you've had two slept with well no I know
I didn't even know one in high school I
had no idea you know in break they
didn't they didn't get into all the
circles that's like a real Midwest weird
stuff I think yeah I don't yeah I don't
think that's a Long Island thing selphie
not like a Philly New York fault like
yeah it's not very
- like the Juggalos yeah it's real
Midwest that's what like the meeting of
the Juggalos is or whatever it's always
like I don't like Detroit or something
would you go would you go to concerts in
the summer like outdoor concerts like
yeah Kitty vest likes Warped Tour and
everything and like you know great
warmth or there's it was no effects mm I
know affects you Molly
Big D in the kids table anti-flag Bad
Religion that's that's a really good and
all the Mountain Dew Code Red you can
drink baby all right anybody in your
house or anybody in your extended family
ever live on a houseboat no that's a bad
luck if you end up on water if you can't
get on land
you know you [ __ ] up somewhere yeah no
that never happened I didn't even know
anybody that owned a boat okay anything
how how do you feel about the rotisserie
chicken from the supermarket because I
gotta tell you before you answer we're
two big fans over here I am a huge fan
of their artistic I wrote chick baby we
got a podcast you ever sucked the string
never did you take the string off and
then you go just kind of lick it up
no only of you not that I would admit
publicly holy uses it in his shoes dude
I don't know I make a belt 45 chickens I
don't know what they put in that [ __ ]
roto bought that thing for and it's like
six bucks six bucks out the door you got
a whole chicken we would buy that like
when my friends were driving around Long
Island and [ __ ] and we were like I'm
hungry we would just go to the
supermarket buy that and like eat it in
the parking lot yeah
wow that's real have some respect you
get a taquito or something I was like an
old man I walked through the parking lot
of a supermarket and saw two kids eat
the [ __ ] rotisserie chicken in the
parking lot
goddamn country's going to hell hey dad
have you ever worn a t-shirt or do you
still wear a t-shirt in the pool we went
swimming right now would you be wearing
a t-shirt if we went if we threw a party
at a story of Park and rented out the
pool and there was a bunch of female
comics there and a bunch of people would
you swim in your t-shirt no I wouldn't
because I would go in the water body but
in the pool I would show up to the pool
in jeans I just brushed my teeth I can't
no but I did that for a couple of years
we're like couple summers I was going
into the pool with my shirt on I've done
it before - that reminds me little known
fact about Brendan sagol Oh Brendan you
know one of the questions on our garbage
will be do you have any tattoos what you
do have tattoos and I think it's no
secret that the trashiest tattoo that
you have is you have a tattoo of a
famous famous author on your chest
correct technically yeah I'm aware I'm
aware and this is what makes you a
hundred percent gormak I knew this one
there's a hunter s Thompson but it's
actually from the cover of fear and
loathing the movie actually Johnny did
God do you have a tattoo of somebody
faint do you have a tattoo of the actor
who played somebody famous
you know yes I do I had horn or playing
Hunter s Thompson on my chest Jesus I
didn't know that that's right next to my
heart oh yeah when he said altar I
thought you had I thought you have the
GAR Alstyne or somebody JK Rowling got
Longfellow on his dick
have you ever vandalized in the name of
skateboarding yeah I got either died bro
yeah I got suspended from middle school
for a week because I drew the
independent Iron Cross in the bathroom
so like the Iron Cross was banned from
my school cuz it was like a Nazi symbol
but I only knew it as the skateboard
yeah open e so I like stood up against
the man and I would be drawing it on
everything and I drew it a huge one in
the bathroom a huge Iron Cross in the
bathroom and then I got suspended for
six weeks not six weeks one week I got
suspended for six weeks in high school a
lot of time in the den it's gonna be the
name of my memoir three weeks in the den
slide your food in under the door
go ahead kit I questions growing up did
your mom make Crescent dinner rolls any
any Pillsbury products that you would
pop out of that can and make make that
no my mom wouldn't cook we would get we
would get delivery almost every night
that's right or my mom would microwave a
hamburger patty with cheese on it for me
wait putting raw hamburger patty she'd
take it from the fridge and she put it
on a she'd put it on a plate and then
she put the plate in the microwave with
cheese on it and she'd microwave her for
like two minutes and then they gave that
to me dan they should they should have
took you guys away from somebody should
have intervened at some point I thought
that was normal I tried to do microwave
burgers
that's not normal yeah my friend came
over and I said do you want a burger and
I put it in the microwave and he
wouldn't need it I would have left him
in for money what happened to your
friend Kevin he doesn't call me anymore
doesn't answer my calls uh did your did
your family growing up did you
have a window unit AC was there any
window it's sticking out of the second
oh we had a we had a real Lacey like one
that was I have a window AC right now
yeah dude I just had this conversation
last night you can have I don't care
what [ __ ] central air system you got
you got a small room and a window unit
cranking on [ __ ] 60 tech nothing gets
colder than that dog running when I
sleep it shut you out of the world -
that's a coldness down to the bone
smell the freon in the air oh man they
get dude and it's all I only put it on
the highest thing at the lowest
temperature they give me the remote I
[ __ ] throw it out I snap it and I'm
like I'm never gonna need this oh yeah I
just leave it on leave it on [ __ ] 55
going just [ __ ] crushing it alright
this one I got this is so I spent a lot
of time with my family my family is the
more it's more time I spend with them
are [ __ ] pure Philly trash like pure
a buck in uncultured unadulterated
Philly trash when you Thanksgiving
dinner right Thanksgiving dinner you
hate your habit whatever is there
ketchup on the table at Thanksgiving oh
no no there's not there anything on the
table
let's start cheese on it
[Laughter]
my cousin
puts ketchup on Thanksgiving dinner oh
that's so gross that's trash
I'm going turkey on just em all over the
top like it's [ __ ] salt and pepper
you think it's a girl
Wow what does this bruiser look like I
gotta [ __ ] you
what's she running about a deuce loose
in a quarter what do we got here I gotta
see this Bucks County three but you got
coming up never seen it they were
talking about it opened up on the beach
I was like what the [ __ ]
ketchup Thanksgiving dinner you should
keep ah sounds like a keeper I don't
know
yeah she's seen anybody or yeah brings
around I'm doing it with your teeth yeah
I have a question too but I want to know
what was what was your mom's go-to
delivered delivery oh my god
on a school night I saw fries every
night yeah pizza and Peking kitchen a
Chinese place around the block from us
was huge I would have liked I would just
always come home after school to
spareribs and Bryce combo every night
was Friday night it's a sack I got
another food one this is real telling I
found out just from my own personal
experience of looking back when I first
had this experience very telling of a
trashy a family is when if ever was the
first time you've had lobster if I had
it once I had it once at my friend Sam's
house once it was leftovers that his dad
brought home and he gave it to my buddy
Sam and I was like can I have one I
hated it poor kid say I think I'm
allergic to BMWs the claw hidden under
your pillow till I was 32 32 years old
was the first time I had lobster
oh that was always the trashy move at
the Foley house when there was ever a
New Year's Eve pop would go a couple of
lobsters some mussels little shrimp go
crab boil in the Delaware River
attention a little different he wasn't
behind them the lobsters were screaming
before you put it in that way yeah man
we were a crab family crabs is a whole
nother story I mean cuz there but we
don't ever Nicola MA
we had sushi a lot yeah alright like the
sushi rolls where it comes in that
plastic thing with that fake grass you
know
yeah that's strip of green whatever that
is that's at least I mean you know
that's better than chicken nuggets an
apple sauce or whatever
well that was there as well so I was I
had some Purdue [ __ ] now gets shaped
like the dinosaurs over the weekend oh
oh because they were making them for the
kids good night
SAG's did you guys have a pool yeah we
had a we had above-ground pool nice in
the shape of a it was just a circle like
it was the worst we I think we did talk
I think we talked about this we're like
the only fun that you can have in this
thing is running along the sides of it
and we're gonna create a whirlpool
whirlpools were fun though yeah it was
like if you if you tried to bring like
like a thing to lay on it would take up
most of the pool so you would just be in
the center just floating I'm moving
anywhere just floating on it not the big
boy at the Foley house Kip you got a
look at that thing you Foley is fully
above-ground pool is like almost Olympic
size dude it's like steel and that puppy
up there dude it's like a regular sized
pool but above-ground you still have it
I couldn't get rid of it now I'm still
rocking and rolling Club holy [ __ ]
come on down that's crazy dude in your
backyard did you have an electric bug
zapper
oh but we should have because one of the
windows was infested with wasps you just
be like yeah wasp man like what every
year yeah yeah it was it's hard to
describe but there's like a window into
the kitchen and then there was like a
little hole on the outside of it and you
just see wasps fly in there so it's like
you can hang out in the backyard as long
as you don't bother the loss talking
about the neighbors did you did you have
who cut the grass was it you and your
dad or did you have a service
landscapers okay that's admirable that's
admirable
but you are a garbage out that is you
got money for the landscaper this is
where you can't get a hot meal and
they're separated he's living in your
room this is insane I know it's my
trashiness is very subtle it's it's you
have to you have to put the pieces
together like a math problem so it's
like we could have fun and summer how
subtle it is you look like you're
broadcasting from a shower right you
thought you guys had some money which
you're probably now they probably did
what every night that's quiche if you're
ordered in for entrees at night from
Peking Duck we went to Disney World
every every year every wax museum as a
family yeah we went to the wax museum in
Paris when I was nine you went to a wax
meat you went to Paris and ended up in a
wax museum is there Dorney Park Europe
over here I get these kids into [ __ ]
a wax museum not the Eiffel Tower and
the sean's of the day the Louvre
we went to Madame Tussauds so that was
kind of French no there's one in the
[ __ ] there's one on 43rd Street what
do you
[Laughter]
you could have taken the Long Island
Rail Road to the [ __ ] wax easy yeah
you do it in the [ __ ] the most
beautiful city in the world
oh it's so funny alright I think I only
got one more for you where do we go from
here I mean what the [ __ ]
so what wait what do you assume in my
trash still we're still on the fence
about it I got one I got two more okay
growing up did you have ever have one of
the following a remote-control boat or a
remote-control helicopter oh I had a
remote-control helicopter work properly
no it broke after like a couple days but
we also had those like science
experiment Rockets little engines yeah
the little thing go and then you have
like chase it or something yeah you want
to hear a real nerd story I stayed I was
in the rocket club one time and
elementary school Wow rockets like a
couple of [ __ ] zeros after this we're
all going to the Wawa growing up this is
this is kind of like new money trash did
you have in the 90s or 2000s did you
have premium cable channels yeah we had
like DirecTV and stuff though yeah we
had the dish I don't care what premium
package you haven't it's coming
satellite did you yeah the dish yeah the
satellite so every time it rained it
would like like you couldn't watch TV or
anything like that yeah you couldn't
follow the local weather cuz you didn't
get local news channels so you never
knew what it was gonna rain yeah and we
got like I was a boy I was doing stuff
but we would buy it but it was [ __ ]
yeah
and that's that's new money that's what
somebody gets in there like this is the
new technology drill this on the side of
my house oh man my fate on it is kneel
to that day like new money gotta get the
thing that's new gotta get like my mom
always gets the new iPhone if a new
iPhone comes out she's got it and she
she does the same thing she'll say it
the same way I got the new iPhone he'll
say just like that he's got nothing to
live for it my kids a malnourished but I
got how many nights a week would you say
did you guys used to eat at the table
that would you would you try to put in
front of the coffee table from the TV oh
I ate standing up at the at like the how
do I describe this silence like the like
a like a like a tabletop but it wasn't a
table you know like where the drawers
are and everything yeah
counter by the sink a counter the
counter yeah I would with and we had a
TV in the kitchen I know was bad I
didn't know so I would watch that and
I'd watch like Bernie Mac show or
Simpsons or whatever and eat Chinese for
holy [ __ ] yeah we never hit at the table
together your mother ever bummed the
cigarette off of you
she bummed one off of my friend Luke
[Laughter]
dude we always thought that was so cool
we were like oh who's your crashed
I don't wait I thought the same thing
and now as you get older you realize
that's [ __ ] garbage yeah that is real
garbage dude if you think it's cool that
your mom is bumming a cigarette off a
child you're contracted ain't no two
ways around it that isn't God buys you
have you ever have you ever stolen weed
from your parents no my parents didn't
smoke my next question was did your mom
ever steal weed from you I was I know
don't know about that maybe maybe she
did I bet a couple bags little light she
would still like my bowls to keep away
from me okay now she's parenting okay I
say we see where the line is all right
fair enough okay yeah what else you got
kid you got anything else that's it
buddy I'm out I want to see if I have
one more for mr. sang oh um this is kind
of a moot point but never used spray on
deodorant oh yeah of course of course
dude the the extreme one remember
extreme where the it would point up and
bam margera was the spokesperson for it
Bam Margera could have sold you just
about anything he could have told me to
kill my parents
do you ever think about trying to create
your own show like that oh yeah me my
friends films [ __ ] like I think I all we
would like throw ourselves in shopping
cart dude if you got a hold of a
shopping cart as a teenager in the
suburbs right around jackass was out
somebody was breaking something for sure
we would like we would have our own
little thing mixed with skate videos but
we're like bad skaters so it's like yeah
us jumping on a curb or whatever and
then it would go to us me like
pretending to fall and fall like with a
milkshake or something
whose Bru don't love to get my hands on
those puppies that are kind of footage I
got to hold it SDA stupid dumbass MTV
wasn't going for it unbelievable can you
believe we didn't get greenlit who
woulda thunk one of my absolute favorite
people we work together a lot
we take rides home together a lot we
ride home together we have a fun time I
absolutely love you to death mr. Brendan
sagol Oh ladies and gentlemen just pure
like this is what I want it like this is
just just the trash
it's just trash it's beautiful American
garbage I appreciate it guys I love you
all you both very much
and I've won money on this show for a
minute to talk about my [ __ ] life and
I gotta be honest it did not diss I
thought I had an idea but man that
[ __ ] blew me away
oh yeah what was two things the craziest
two things amazing your dad you slept in
the den whatever and then you went to
the you went to a [ __ ] wax museum in
France that's insane yeah yeah that's
like go with the New York oh that's like
that's like going to [ __ ] New York
from Poland and going to watch a movie
or something my-my dad
my dad would have had to fight me to get
my room at 12 years old I don't know I
would have fought him well I also had it
was there like that sad Saturday morning
well you're like taking your posters
down like getting like he got fired from
a job but he's your stuff in a box well
I mean let me give my theory he I think
he was so he wanted that a little bit
because that's not what he was he wanted
like the delinquent chat the angst of
like I don't even have the room I sleep
on the [ __ ] couch and like yeah I'm
gonna be a [ __ ] punk rocker and
bedrooms you know what I mean whatever
they want like the thought of my parents
getting divorced made me go oh man
everybody's gonna be giving me attention
and I'm gonna be this cool kid with like
a divorced parent you know like I looked
forward to the pain makes thing you know
you're not talking to the wasps we were
right before the everything way before
Corona broke me and you work together by
last weekend working really was yeah
have any like live with with Posey and
we were drunk this is how ingrained and
trashy as we get to the toll which is 16
bucks he goes OH
man sixteen bucks with it soul that's
expensive and then just turned his head
and didn't even reach for his [ __ ]
wallet Thank You Manny
anyone who man their 2016 buses its
whole hot stinks where I'm from you're
driving you're paying that toll oh yeah
no I did
obviously I mean you weren't you mean if
it was up to you to pay we'd still be
standing there wait we're also making
more money than me though weekend yeah
this is inside baseball man who hosted
and who featured I think I hosted he
hosted I featured yet yeah there you go
Kevin should pay the toll yeah yeah rich
cap plus you got the cash too it's kids
sleeping in the [ __ ] den have a
little [ __ ] sympathy yeah ten kids
bad kids I keep sending letters to Bam
Margera for help he's not getting back
to me paper sacks is everything you want
the the gang out there to know that they
might might not already know where can
we find you know follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at Brandon silo listen to
my podcast garbage days it has nothing
to do with what you guys are doing but
same word and then I have another
podcast called what's the scenario it's
a patreon exclusive podcast so with
Feeny my canon yeah and we ask each
other questions like what what what ifs
and what would you do and scenarios and
stuff like that and it's really fun yeah
I probably should have said those for
your for your instructor yeah you said
you said a lie that I put on my bio
writer for just writer for joking off
well that's real that actually I like
that you use Rob Lowe cuz that's not
that's like right there in the middle
that that's not gonna raise any
questions from anybody get one of my
jokes on the just one joke is on the
roast sorry you are nearly and buy them
but you wrote on it oh yeah I the person
who said my joke didn't even know I
wrote it mmm
cuz I gave it to someone you were gave
it to a writer then who gave it to them
yeah yeah yeah it's the way this game
works baby yeah keeps getting sadder and
sadder as the episode goes on doesn't it
ladies and gentlemen come on our good
pal mr. Brennan Sangalo Brennan thank
you so much Kippy anything you want the
folks out there to know if you haven't
already please make sure you rate review
subscribe on iTunes also full video
available on YouTube you can check it
out there a lot of people commenting
stuff like that also patreon if you
haven't already you can join the patreon
that thing is starting to get cooking we
just started this week and we're almost
or halfway to our first goal hundred
patrons and at a hundred patrons we will
go to Foley's [ __ ] parents house and
do a garbage style and TV cribs and I am
going to turn that place out dude [ __ ]
yeah I was mollis that thing I was there
this week looking around just thinking
like oh man he's gonna [ __ ] kill me
for these they can't be there when I do
that by the way I'm not having your
[ __ ] bluff you're dumb mom and dad
look at me why i trashed their life my
parking old dad is gonna get a shotgun
after hearing your [ __ ] bosses house
is balls all day i'll send them out to
[ __ ] rob you know red lobster or
something for the day and the king where
are we eating Chinese place peking
kitchen which i tried to get a job at
when i was 15 i tried to I gave them my
I asked for an application and they
laughed in my face
yeah I'm not having a go place they
asked for an application application
yeah can't we just like I don't want to
work with you guys thanks for having me
man yeah buddy thank you man this was so
much fun we appreciate you I will see
you soon buddy thank you later later
later pal